Tom has one thing that sets him apart
from the other Spider-Man his impressive
Dance and Gymnastics background this
definitely came in handy when it came to
doing his own stunts for Spider-Man far
from home and I really appreciate that I
didn't break anything Whenever there
were any stunts that were too dangerous
for Tom to do stunt doubles would step
in but Tom still had to get very used to
doing backflips off of trampolines and
flying around on wire for this role but
Tom's scariest stun for this movie would
have to be the time that he and Zendaya
were hoisted 100 feet into the air on a
crane with a body cam strapped to them
are you too good I got you I got you the
only thing protecting them from a nasty
fall were a couple of cardboard boxes
placed for safety they were dropped and
swung in a massive Arc with Zendaya
screaming the whole time never never
doing that again but Tom would much
rather be dangling a hundred feet in the
air than dealing with the mental strain
of the crowded room